Alright. Alright, welcome to the
DDPS seminar everyone people we
introduce our invited speaker,
let's go over some rules and
logistics are first of all,
please mute yourself during the
talk. But if you have questions,
you can unmute and ask
questions, or use chatroom to
post your questions so that we
can address them in q&a session
at the end. Second, today's DDPS
seminar is open to external
audiences. Therefore, no
classified discussion is
allowed. So please watch out.
Finally, the talk today will be
recorded and uploaded in our
YouTube channel. That's about
it. Now let me briefly introduce
our speaker today. It is an
honor to Dr. Francesco Romer,
who is a postdoctoral researcher
in the numerical mathematics and
Scientific Computing Group
computing group at the vices
stress Institute for Applied
analysis and Stoke has
stochastics in Berlin, Germany.
He received his PhD in 2023 in
mathematical analysis, modeling
and applications from the
International School of Advanced
Studies in three Asda Italy, is
this is supervised by Professor
John loogie, Rosa and Professor
Giovanni's Istanbul, focused on
the nonlinear parameter space
and motor order reductions
enhanced by scientific machine.
Today, Francisco will talk about
intrusive modal or the reduction
of parametric PDE s, using
neural networks approximants of
the solution manifold and
adaptive hyper reductions. I'm
sure we are going to hear a
wonderful talk from San
Francisco. Oh, let me ask a
question to Francisco just to
get to know him better. There
you go. Okay, I happen to know
that you are passionate about
dancing. Yeah. What kind of
dancing Do you like to do and if
you can describe what it is and
how it how it how it works?
Briefly? That would be awesome.
Okay.
Well, it started years ago even
before COVID to dance, Lindy
Hop, also here in Europe. And
yeah, it's a it's a very lovely
environment and a way to
differentiate yourself from
coding and math. Let's say it's
more focused work job. Yeah, I
guess everybody knows it,
please. What's what Lindy Hop is
my yah yah, yah, I suggest you
to look into it into YouTube as
an aura.
Yeah, I will. Definitely yes,
yes, you increased my curiosity
about that. Great and the stage
is yours. Thank you, thank
you for the introduction. And
so, I will present the work I've
done during my PhD studies at
Sisa in collaboration with John
instability and geology razza
the work is about an extension
of the production of the
nonlinear manifold method and
before introducing it, I will
present some motivations behind
the new methodology. So,
introduce the linear manifold
methods starting from the
finance element passing through
the reduce basis method. So, if
you have in mind the most simple
PDE like the Poisson problem,
you can write the weak
formulation in this way. And you
can discretize it in space and
choose your discretization
method of choice for example,
the thing doesn't matter. In
this case, your answer space
will be a space of continuous
functions that are restricted
locally to the elements of the
triangulation are polynomial of
degree k. But you could also
choose spectral global basis
orthonormal functions on the
world domain if a domain is nice
and but what about if you have
additional parameters on your
PDB for which you have to find
solutions, and these parameters
may affect the geometry of the
competition domain or under as
deficient parameters in your
weak formulation or in your
sorcerer? Well, in this case,
you could exploit some solutions
you have computed before
beforehand even called Training
stage to tailor specific asset
space for this problem to infer
new solutions corresponding to
parameters you have not seen
yet. And this is very as many
relationship with the using
these spectra this method on the
world domain instead in this
case, we will use a smaller
dimensionality reduced basis. So
still linear basis, but tailored
for your problem. So this is
more or less the nomenklatura
model reduction. So, you want to
find to find solution u h, for
this week formulation, and you
introduce a parameter space K to
which your parameter mu belongs
to the solution map L from the
that gives that map's each
parameter to solution, the
solution manifold which is the
image of the parameter space to
the solution map. And in a
training stage, usually
collectors call the snapshot
matrix. So, for different
parametric instances from one to
N train their respective
solutions. Once you've done
this, you consider the same
formulation but instead as
answer space, you want to find
your solution as a linear
combination of a few number of
modes, let's say our with our
very small with respect to the
full dimensionality of your
state space. And this linear
combination is made with a
vector on the global basically
in relation also in with a lot
of analogies with the spectral
basis method honorable domain,
but in this case, the elements
of your basis will come from a
singular value decomposition of
yours natural matrix. And of
course, the idea behind model
reduction is that you amortize
the cost of compute in addition,
an additional and training
snapshot in order to to infer
efficiently new solution at the
prediction or online stage. So,
of course, this sometimes is not
sufficient to approximate
accurately as solution because
you model reduction usually you
sacrifice accuracy in terms in
favor of competition as molar
computational cost, but in some
cases, this is not enough and
you need approximate which are
not linear in a sense. So, I
will present today how you can
use as answer space nonlinear
mappings. So in a linear answer
space for your solution, and how
you can solve for a solution in
an efficient way. In this case,
for example, you can consider as
answer space the image through
an nonlinear map fee instead of
a linear map from an open set in
the space of dimensionality our
width are still very smaller
with respect to the full
dimensionality of our state
space. And of course, the
problems of using a linear
reduce basis is very well known
individual and can be explained
simply with looking at the
reduction of escargot transport
problem. So, in this case, the
condition is zero and you have a
boundary condition equal to one.
So, basically the solution if
you consider a standard
deviation is one followed by
zeros, so, it is continuous and
at the next time instant will be
one one followed by 0111
followed by zero, if you
assemble the snapshot matrix,
where the columns correspond to
your solutions at different time
instances, in this case, time is
the only parameter and then you
evaluate the Eigen modes with
the SVD you can then plot the
residual energy of your system.
And you can see that even with
different levels of visitation
from more or less 100 to 2000,
you can see that you need more
than the 80% of your mods to
retain more than 95% of your of
the energy of the system. This
in comparison to for example,
the incompressible navier stokes
equations. So, typical benchmark
for pasty cylinder and
implemented in the integral
field volume inside the open
form and you will see that you
within less than 5% of the of
your Eigen function of the Eigen
modes to retain more than 95% of
the energy of the whole system.
So, even if it's a more complex
problem to solve the it's more
easy in this in to to reduce
with reduce basis matter
innocence and a lot of practical
applications of this problem.
And to be more quantitative,
it's the concept of Kolmogorov
and weight is introduced. So,
you consider parameter space K
sub sub sub set of parameter
space calligraphic P and you can
find the Komagata and wait for
as for a fixed Dimension ID and
of your linear approximation
space as the best approximation
error uniform with respect to
the solution manifold and the
camera with has been evaluated
for its asymptotic has been
evaluated in many studies. And
you can see that even for the
incompressible and the stokes
equations using considering as
parameter, the search term
itself as a function, you have
almost you have exponential
decay minus n 111 divided by
three times some constants. And
also the famous case for Lena
corsi problems of exponential
decay, but also more difficult
to prove for solution mapping
which are automorphic you can
find approximations acidotic
estimates like this. So, for for
perimeter which is a function of
regularity as you have this kind
of estimates. And of course, for
the interaction problem I
presented before also wave
equation you would have instead
a lower bound of n to the minus
one of these strictly depends
also on the initial conditions.
So, it's important to notice
that not every infection
immunity problem as this kind of
come about our local Morgana,
ATK in fact, a lot depends on
the regularity of the initial
conditions and also the variety
of the parameter to solution
map. And more generally, also
it's it may happen that in
practical applications, even if
you have a synthetic local
Magara with a que you may still
reach a sufficient accuracy with
a sufficient a sufficiently
small number of modes. So, it
does not mean that if you have a
very slogan predicate and you
cannot approximate your problem
at all it depends case by case.
Yeah, and also as you said not
this problem, this problem of
local McDonald's with the K
affects not only addiction
immunity problems, but a lot of
applications. Like for example,
problems with the
parameterization that change the
computational domain or more
complex models with complex
dynamics and smaller scales in
your dynamics, etc. So, auto
erasure, these are some
references some methodologies,
which researchers have tried to
solve this problem. So, some of
them are congruent as local
methodologies like the
medicalization or interpolation
on space parameters. Some others
take inspirations from machine
learning earlier dimension
reduction techniques, I cannot
base methods. Some others from
imaging sciences, like old
techniques like restriction
apply, for example, in 2014, for
registering geometries. And more
recently, also of encoders, so,
in the last several years of
living carpark, and today I'm
going to talk about an extension
of data methodology with AI
production. So, auto encoders
have been bred also in the model
reduction community and sort of
modeling community. Also, thanks
to the advent of ResNet and cn
NS from the 2010 to 2015 16. And
also with the with the
development of open source
software like Python TensorFlow
available for everybody. And
especially, these are some of
the first works I managed to
fund on
auto encoder micro CNNs used as
purely data driven methods in
competition for dynamics. So, a
lot of techniques also nowadays,
are structured like this in so,
they are pulling the trigger
neurons, and they have the task
of surrogate model is divided in
two steps, let's say even you
sometimes they perform at the
same time. So, the first step is
to approximate the solution
manifold. And so, the basically
architecture you have is an
autoencoder. So, with a an
encoder map, see from the full
state dimension to a reduce
latent dimension R and the
decoder and the decoder map from
the latent dimension R to the
full state D. And then you have
another natural that whose job
is to infer and to learn the
lesson dynamics of your system.
So, if you if you plug in
different parameters, for
example, also time and you
produce solute the solution but
inside this molar latent space,
of course, individually, there
are many examples in which the
architecture changes. So for
example, you can use for the
solution manifold learning
problem convolutional encoder,
variational auto encoders,
against their sigle, decoders
LSDM auto encoder to enhance by
using auto there are many tools
available right now. And also
for the later 90s. You can use a
Gaussian process regression
before now network LSDM, causal
convolution networks and RLDS.
There are many other artists.
But these are only boring data
driven methods. This means that
there isn't a training stage and
a predictive phase. But in the
predictive phase, you only plug
in your inputs, your parameters,
for example, time and other
parameters of your parameter TBD
and get the solution. Instead,
what we want you to do is to
preserve in a sense, the
physics. So instead of abusing
this paradigm, we wanted to find
a solution or Title line stage
in a sense solving keeping
keeping in mind the numerical
scheme using the Florida model.
So, for example, minimizing
first principles and this is
something that you cannot do
with standard data driven roms
that discard completely the
physic in the physics in the
predictive phase. So, the
original work introduced by the
carbo is can be presented like
this. So, you first discretize
your permittivity in space and
you obtain an OD. So, in this
case, you represent your state
variables. So, you saw the
physical field can be stacked
together for example, for an
incompressible navier stokes
equations, you would have a plus
the pressure and you would then
obtain and these enter the
system where f is your vector
field and can be also a
nonlinear depending on your
body. And of course, the initial
condition and you can discretize
it in time. And it is where you
have received Well, that depends
on the parameter of course, but
also on the time instant you're
solving for the full solution
and also the previous time
instance instances belonging
belonging to the interval it and
this creation of the initial
condition. For example, for the
implicit order method, the
formulation of the residual like
this one. So, this is the boxes
compare the least square Petrov
Galerkin method, it's an
application of are these spaces
with no linear manifold SPG. And
you can see the difference is
often the choice of answer
space. So on the least square
but we're lucky method, you
start from letting reduce
coordinates it's 00 that you've
obtained after a linear
projection of your initial
condition is zero. And this you
this PR matrix is just the
matrix whose columns are the
Eigen modes of your SVD for
example, of your as an option
matrix. So, what you do next is,
if you have time parameter you
can see there you have to find
the solution at the next time
step. So, in this lesson, what
problems can we imagine the
receiver and in this case,
instead of the state UD Hu
plugin, their construction from
the latent variables be outside.
Of course, if your PD has an A
find the composition with
respect to the parameters, you
can save the use matrices or
flying, the proceeds will be
efficient. But if you're still
for example, is not linear, then
you would need to apply I
production techniques to make it
to make these solving this
problem independent from the
number of degrees of freedom.
So, on the right side instead,
you see that using encoder and
decoder, so, the linear maps is
easy as just plugging in them
inside it the position of the
state would be considered
before. And so, now, to find the
initial reduced variable, you
would use the encoder and encode
the initial conditions and then
you will devote the ramekin the
latent space always with a small
dimensionality R, but in this
case, the state will be
reconstructed from the latent
space to the full state space
through the decoder fee. So,
this is the formulation if you
want to think about it,
graphically, you have on this on
the left side a plane which is
our vector space spanned by the
Eigen modes of SPD that
approximates this kind of
AnnaLena manifold, while you can
see that dynamics is evolved in
the latent space, and only the
and reconstructed on the
solution manifold. Why on the
right you want to try to
approximate your solution
manifold with the unknown linear
approximate map. So in the
annual survey Nandina
representation of your solution
manifold, of course, now, if
your residual is in the
beginning linear, you introduced
nonlinear math, so you will need
to solve a nonlinear least
square problem. If you see there
isn't a linear you're able to be
in a linear but you add in
additionally non linearity
coming from the decoder. And
there are many mythologies that
can be used to simulation
algorithms can be used to solve
the linear scale problem around
them Quasi Newton methods and
also other variants like
pounders implemented in Patsy
that we that is what we use for
the benchmark a person today,
but also the lead member Monica
are going to address this for
other benchmarks in other
references from the inside the
eigen library. And of course,
the problem is that as in the
original implementation of Lean
Karlberg, you still have a
different dependency on the full
dimensionality of your state
space. And so, even with this
formulation, it may happen that
your use of the model is even
more inefficient than your full
order model. So we need to apply
some sort of AI production and
of course the full
dimensionality. I mean, there
Silla has full dimensionality
but also the state space. And
one of the simplest approaches
is to use our collocation
method. So, you define a metric
matrix which restricts the
receiver only on some colocation
nodes. And of course, if you
consider standard methods like
the G fam or volumes, then if
you want to evaluate the receipt
well locally on single nodes,
even just a stencil around them
for because the differential
operators over this condition or
this condition are defined only
locally, of course, these maps
are passed inside the civil
definition. And you what you
just need to do is restrict the
reconstructed state space on the
on the sub mesh B as our h and
in the end, so you can restrict
the receiver G to the only and
then coefficient nodes and the
output of the decoder only on
this mesh. Of course, there are
many other implementation or
production, there is a there is
a dime there is a C SW there is
not there is also an OPT, which
improve the bind selection
algorithm. And, yeah, but of
course, I will show maybe some
examples of the submissions if
you the first time you've seen
it. So in red, you see the
collocation nodes, so only the
nodes in which the results
evaluated. And in blue, in light
blue in the nodes, the cells
that are you make make make part
of the mesh. So on this two
grids are the grades come from
two benchmarks that I've used in
another experiment and produce
it later maybe. And but you can
see that this is a nonlinear
conservation law problem with
the with the parameters also
time so you can see moving from
from the left bottom corner to
the right top corner. And this
is the shallow water equation,
should it be the solution should
have a radial symmetry. But you
can see that there's a mesh size
depends on the numerical scheme
you're using. So for example,
you could have only one layer
around each single node of your
residual or more layers around
them. And of course, the problem
is that now you use a decoder,
with Jeremy be a very big map.
And so you need to find also
ways to or define shallow or
thin architectures that are at
the same time, shallow and so
efficient to evaluate many times
and accurate or you can, you
have to find other techniques to
solve this problem. So, these
are the references I could find
above about extensions of the
linear manifold method. And all
of them use APA reduction in a
way. So the first reference was,
of course by Kim Jung said
earlier that they use the
shallow masculine colors we
tried in, we attempted to use
convolutional decoder and then
approximate the decoder with
with a smaller one in a second
side we teach to their training.
So it's a part of the machine
learning to train, it's more
than it was from bigger models,
let's say. So that it could we
could have an efficient small
network, we're using our
nonlinear propagation to solve
the nearest square problem. But
there are also other approaches
in Indonesia that consider for
example decoders, we've seen
some sub meshes, or by
production, or that split the
unary and approximate in a
linear part and the linear part,
but Otieno is a composition with
a nonlinear part made of an
arrow network, or an approach
that I'm going to present today.
And also, of course, approaches
consider party partitioning
approaches. So the main
composition in each the
composition of a domain you
consider in your watercolor and
performing this way of
production. And so the approach
I'm going to talk about today is
the following. It relies a lot
on the technique vary with by
the machine learning which is
which consider using SVD as pre
processing steps to extract
meaningful features from your
database. For example, if you
have in mind efficient processes
and stable diffusion, so sorted
efficiently model and stable
diffusion so what you do is
purpose in step you extract and
reduce dimensionality of your
image let's say usually with
other architectures, bicycles or
in this case we use SVD or more
generally, I call the filtering
transform map and with the same
in underlying parallel
randomized SVD, which is very
efficient for very big problems
on meshes of more than 1 million
degrees of freedom, but you
could also consider a fast
Fourier transform or other
transformer of your choice. And
so, the architecture is instead
in this case done is as the
structure so you first have Leon
layer that consider, let's say a
matrix with columns, the Eigen
modes of your transform map. For
example, the Eigen modes of
randomized SVD that projects
your state space from D to A
dimensionality P, the
dimensionality of the frequency
space, let's call it and then
from you want to reconcile this
frequency space with a small
auto encoder made of four neural
networks are one these units.
And so these are the color maps
these frequency space B to
reduce the dimensionality are,
and they're reconstructed back
with fee tilde and decoder from
R to p, where p is much smaller
than the Sobeys. That would be
the number of your ad space is
most for example, and, and but
in with respect to where the
spaces applications display can
be much higher. So usually for
these spaces can be less than
50. Most, let's say, in our
applications, b is equal to 300.
Because it shifts accuracy in a
very efficient way with
undermines video in this way,
regarding the reconstruction
error, and finally, ever linear
projection from B to the full
state space d dimensionality. Of
course, if you consider you as a
value h, you consider many
fields stuck together, and you
can we applied a monolithic SVD.
And of course, have to
renormalize the fields because
you may have pressure and
velocity or other fields. And so
you need to apply a weight that
say make it the state space
independent from the unit of
measure and out there. On the on
the physical quantity you're
considering, let's say, in this
way, you obtain a more accurate
extraction error, because you
only randomize video. So now you
have, let's repeat a very small
and fast and fast to evaluate
decoder from RTP because it's
just from the latent space to
the frequency space. So, the
space that you obtained
projecting the your snapshot,
and then you have a linear
projection F minus one filter
from this frequency space p to
the four dimensional and why
this choice architecture is very
useful for our applications,
because then you can apply AI
production very efficiently
because yeah, very fast network
evaluate. And then you can if
you want to apply a production,
and you have selected as a mesh,
and what you need to do is just
restrict the rows which are
brand representatives of the of
your of your of your system, you
can just erase them if you if
they do not belong to your sub
mesh. And what you find that
it's just this nonlinear
approximate composed by a
nonlinear part, which is the
same as the quarter part of your
encoder, and then a much smaller
linear map from the frequency
space b to the restriction of
your modes to the sub mesh,
you're considering we do a rapid
reduction technique in our case,
the other collocation so in this
way, you you have found an
accurate in some cases when
otherwise, this VD achieves a
good reconstruction error using
also a lot of modes like three
other modes. Also thin because
you have just you restrict them
in a manner which they which is
the biggest part of your
network, only to have your map
or have your full view of your
altogether on your map only to
the sub mesh. And we wanted to
take a step further and we
wanted to also try an adaptive
strategy since when you consider
a production sometimes, if you
have a fixed mesh, but then the
major components of the of your
receipt will moves during the
evolution of economics. So you
may want to follow these
features of the dynamics with
your magic points. And so, we
want to one way to do this,
because it also that we have an
later map that uses in our
network is the following. So,
you first define a map from set
which are your latent variables
to the simple state space. So
that is map to reconstruct the
state space with the fee, which
I want her to remark is made by
a CT fee tilde, which is an
earlier part and then a linear
part and then this is plugged in
into the residual evaluation and
that it has the full
dimensionality of your state
space. So then you want to
compute sensitivities. So it's
simple chain rule, you see that
there is a component that is the
derivative of the receive
respect to the state a component
is linear with respect to the
reconstruction with linear
reconstruction you're implying
and then a component which is
which Cobian of the output of
your restricted recorder of your
soil is more than a linear
decoder, respect to the latent
variables. So in the end,
evaluate these these
sensitivities. For the choice of
magic points would be too much
expensive. And so, we decided
instead to use this kind of
indicator. So, you we cut off of
this part and we consider only
this part here, which instead
considers only the
reconstruction filter and the
previous late end Layton
coordinates to evaluate the
Jacobian of field. So, in this
way, you have a mapper which is
more efficient to evaluate, but
as a dimensionality from the
latent space are to a matrix D,
which is the dimension to the
state space times are of course,
if you do want to of course,
this depends on the full number
of degrees of freedom, but if
you want to reduce for the
dimensionality you could
consider to restrict this
evaluation only to say enable
with some enable of your actual
sub mesh to make it more the
procedure more efficient and
fully independent inspect to the
number of degrees of freedom,
but for simplicity, we consider
the full state space. And so,
now, you can minimize you can of
course, you have to computer
since your state space has many
physic can have physical fields.
So, like for example, a number
of see physical things like
pressure and velocity, you have
to take the edge sooner with
respect to that, then you take
the airMAX with respect so, you
choose the most influential
influential latent variable. And
then if you decide which are the
cells of your mesh, we are
considering field volume method,
sales of the mesh, which would
correspond to the to the magic
points in which this quantity
this indicator as its maximum
value. Okay, so this for
example, you would have these
kind of some measures that
evolved within Amex in the case
of compressible flow past and
like iPhone, and you can see in
black, the metric points and the
gray the some mesh around them.
And you can see that more or
less follows some important
features of the dynamics from
types of 02 times two seconds.
We also wanted to point out
other important characteristics
of the choice of our
approximate, which is the
possibility to use a local
formulation. Because now for
example, if you have time as
parameter as shown later, you
could, for example, split the
time interval into and decide to
use one reduce one layer basis
for one sub one sub interval or
the time interval and one sub
bases for the other time
interval. Why this procedure is
still efficient, because then
you offline, you could, you
could have two auto encoders,
so, one four sub time interval,
and then online, you would just
offline you can just multiply
the linear basis and online you
will just perform this cheap
change of basis between
P one and P two, let's say lady
mentioned it we are frequency
space. Of course, this is very
simple and maybe naive way to
perform. Say the projection from
one local linear approximation
to one other local linear
approximation, individual two
there are many work that that
make this procedure more
rigorous and take into account
other interface conditions. But
it's a very simple way. And we
wanted to point it out because
it could be used with our
approach if you really want to
do to use a local linear
approximation of your parameter
space. So the first test case
I'm going to consider is
compressible flow, air flow. And
the parameter to consider here
are time and the electron
number. So we took the molar
mass of our gas such that the
speed of sound is equal to one.
And in this way, we can choose
the MCL number as parameter and
set it as the choice of our
inlet velocity from two to five
in the training range, and from
one per day to 2.5 point two in
our test range. So just to give
you a grasp of the solution
manifold, we are considering for
the initial cluster the initial
time steps 0.2 seconds. So the
first and third snapshot with
number 5.2, and 1.8. These are
all in the extrapolation regime.
So these are the let's say the
external solutions. So it's very
big the solution meaningful we
want to approximate and this is
implemented this thing with a
fini volume method in open form
with the sonic form solver. So
if you can see that if you see
if you look into the sonic form
solver and compare it to our
implementation of the manual
method. If see there are some
differences, in fact, the sonic
form solver first of all the
fields were considering are the
velocity, the density field
internal energy and the pressure
field. The sonnet form software
consider predictor corrector and
medical scheme also you consider
a non non orthogonal corrector
because you're when you have
also as in this case not meshes,
but instead in the unreal
mindful method, for each
evaluation of the receiver, we
don't need to to use this reverb
corrector scheme. But instead in
inside the AnnaLena I was quite
optimization at each evaluation
of their syllable, so I teach
and timestamp but also ie if
step of the optimization we need
to we can evaluate just the
receiver in this way. So without
ever using the Full Scheme,
let's say and also of course,
remember that we only evaluate
the receiver on the sub mesh.
Okay, so these are some
predictive solutions to for a
qualitative comparison. And this
is what
Okay, take some times
Okay, as you can see, okay, this
is the full evolution of the sub
mesh. So in this case, we have
considered for this test case 20
training parameters as Mach
number, and five test
parameters. And the test case
I'm showing you a, these are the
snapshots I'm showing you
correspond to the Mach number
2.124. As I mentioned, the
beginning I consider as the
dimensionality of your linear
projection, so p is equal to
300. So we use a three under our
RSP bots, something that maybe
you wouldn't do with the reduced
business model. And we consider
a linear dimensionality of r
equal to four, these numbers are
chosen only to satisfy to
achieve a good accuracy with the
world reconstruction for the
world extraction error. So in
this case, we have used 1200,
adaptive prediction collocation
nodes. And they are updated, not
every time step but only every
20 time steps. Of course, the
choice of when to update them
can be maybe worked out better
with either maybe a posteriori
techniques. And remember that
we're comparison, we're
comparing the competition costs
with the open source open from
solver and in this case, if you
consider a mean time step, we
achieve not much of a speed of
less than two, but you see that
74 milliseconds for evaluation
for a single time step at the
end of the mid foot method is
quite the standard of also if
you consider other works in the
literature, the things that now
we compare with the flow the
model made implementing performs
very high performance solver for
a very simple problem with just
33,000 sounds, but with our
methodology, we also try to
increase the timestamp. So, that
would include in problems for
this if our condition for the
other form level is that we
could use a time step also,
which is four times higher. And
this case we do achieve a speed
up of five for evaluating the
full dynamics in this simple
test case. And I show some
results on the to relative error
for the local linear manifold
application. So, as I told you,
we consider true time intervals
from zero to 1.2 and from 0.6 to
2.5. And we can see the two
different LSVT modes for these
two time intervals and also
other encoders. And we compare
what are the errors with the use
of these two sub intervals or
with the use of one single
subdomain. So in red one single
subdomain and in blue shoe time
intervals of course, in with the
yellow line out the we consider
it five trajectories are plotted
altogether. And the there they
are divided by this gray columns
and in red in shaded red, there
are the except there is the
extrapolation regime, which the
solution is very bad. Errors and
instead when in during inside a
training regime, inside your
training range, you'll see a
yellow vertical line that is
when you perform the change of
bases from one sub interval to
the other and the change is
performed at time 0.6 to five if
I remember correctly, and you
can see that in our case, you
cannot you cannot you cannot get
better approximations with also
with choice of local linear
manifolds. But maybe it's still
good to point out that you could
do it in practice. So the second
test case is instead The aerosol
the ML body. So, we consider the
incompressible navier stokes
equations with the turbulence
model. So, these are morass when
equation turbulence model and
the state we consider in this
case are the velocity, the
pressure and also the Addicks
cottage. So, the turbulence
model is cut off in the end,
when you consider the nonlinear
manifold method. So, the domain
is like this and you consider
200,000 cells, and this test
case has been first considered
for in model reduction, well,
nothing Maharaj community but my
collaborators have been worked
on on this test case previously,
but they consider a stationary
stationary test case. So they
solve the equations with a
simple algorithm. Instead, we
try to predict the transient
dynamics with a piece of
algorithm in open form based on
solver. So, the parameter in
this case, our time time from
zero to one seconds, and this
land angle of the body, we
consider two parametric
instances to parametric ranges,
the first parameter range is
from 15 degree to a bit more
than 18 degrees. And the other
parameter range is higher from
15 to 35. And we'll see what
could go wrong with this
methodology. So, these are the
mechanician. Again, the
presentation. Okay, so, these
are again the evolution this is
again the evolution of the sub
mesh. And in this case, we
consider only five train
parameters and for those
parameters, and I show you the
this is the predicted solution
for as lantai co equal to this
value. And, of course, in this
case, Arabic they're
considerably you want to believe
velocity, pressure and you also
believe the causative and also
in this case, we consider P
equal to then So, the number of
your hours or SBD modes are 300
and the dimensionality of four,
again, these numbers are kept
fixed also in this case, by just
because we could achieve good
accuracy with respect to the
extraction error. So, maybe they
are not optimal value, you will
choose maybe from some
parametric studies to find an L
slower maybe on a higher if you
want to achieve a better
accuracy, for example. So, in
this case, the magic points are
evaluated every 50 time steps.
And in this case, you consider
the mean time step, you would
achieve a bit of speed up at
least if this is still a very
coarse mesh, you know perform.
So, you would achieve at least a
speed of five because the only
the mean time step. But also in
this case, we consider an iron
timestamp with respect to the
farm because we could do it the
reduced level. And in this case,
you can see the full dynamic is
that you're doing a speed up of
26. And of course the maybe you
don't see all this a match
because a big part of the namics
so big the higher the highest
values of the receiver and
evaluated below the helmet body.
So the stills around the stills
there there are the it's
similarly flow plus the cylinder
flow let's say and so that you
can see the residual soil and
also the some mesh follow this
fissures below the body. And
this is also for the pressure
for some more quantitative
estimates. You can see that the
pressure and velocity are quite
good estimated for this test
case. And instead of the
viscosity are much worse
approximations also because it's
more difficult to linearly
approximated in this case. But
of course, I want to remind you
that this is eminently SBD. So,
in a way the pressure velocity
and viscosity are coupled in a
single eigen mode. And of
course, this is still the
parametric domain range from 15
degrees to a bit more than 18
degrees of this land angle.
Instead if you want consider as
parameter range from 15 to 35
there will be some problems and
this happens not only for this
implementation of the mindful
method, but also generally for
applications that consider also
purely data driven methods.
Consider SVT as per person
stuff, and then and only they're
out encoder and then they may be
the learn that dynamics with
another network. This is because
for example, if you see the
there are 13 parameters, so the
first plot the top there is the
so the Shisa corresponds to
different parametric instances
of the land and globally in my
body. So we have divided this
interval in 50 parts and Each
each parameter, you can see 13
training snapshots, and the
colors represent the choice of
SVD modes used to evaluate the
reconstruction error. So, this
is the train to relative error
and this is the test error, and
you can see that increase the
number of modes, there is
parametric sub intervals for
which you cannot achieve a good
accuracy even increase in the
number of months. And this is
very typical for a lot of
applications for which you need,
maybe you think more data or
maybe the linear approximate is
not good. Something you could
try is to use instead lock an
interval local approximation.
So, you may want to let's say
from a sort of clustering of
your parameter parameter space
and decide okay if I divide my
parameter space into four parts,
and then apply SVD in each of
the two part hoping that the
reconstruction would be better
in that case also
considering that you have also
many solutions in that
particular sub domain and for
some sub parametric for some sub
intervals of the parametric
space, you will gain better
approximations, but still not
good enough in the in some
ranges of your in some intervals
of your parametric domain. And
maybe in this cases, other
approaches will be more
preferable with respect to the
linear approximate maybe you
will may want to try to use much
bigger neural network
architectures such as CNN, see,
if your grades of graph neural
networks are more or other
architectures and in this case,
so you cannot use them ontology
I presented because you cannot
use our rscds proposal system.
But you can try to use another
approach we have developed
before. And this uses pictures
to the training. So you first
train very big, etc. For
example, in this case, for the
for AnnaLena conservational
problem, you train a
convolutional auto encoder from
a grid to a grid. And then after
training it you can train a
smaller decoder that will use in
your layer mind format. And this
decoder is made by just two
hidden layers. And they it's
very simple feed forward and
backward, that is evaluated from
the left hand coordinates to
just the sub mesh to the states
of your training database, but
only restricted to the sub mesh.
So you have done a very smaller
NyQuil to use for your nonlinear
mathematics. And so I briefly
summarize the conclusion and
possible pros and cons of the
mythology. So what you have with
respect to data driven
procedures is an interpretable
procedure. So it's more
explicable as a result, because
at each time step, you are
minimizing first principle so so
you're minimizing physical
quantities. And it's more
interpretable respect to
blackbox approaches in which you
plug in parameters and you get
the solutions. But at the same
time, you can also as in data
driven methods that use for
example autoencoders you can
introduce additional inductive
biases. So you can add some
covariance properties, you know
network, or you could add also
positivity of physical
quantities. For example, if you
have a density in your state
space, you can keep this
constraint for example, with a
value activation function, or
simples, other constraints like
a weekly symplectic autoencoder.
One additional guarantee
theoretical guarantees that you
can always methodology with
respect to with respect to data
driven methodologies is to
possibility to introduce also
structure preservation. So, with
this formulation, let's say, you
could also try to implement
additional constraint, because
every time you just you don't
only evaluate an artwork, but
you also minimize within a
Soviet Union, it's quite
problem. So you may want to try
adding energy conserving
property or entropy stable
property for the land
conservation laws. Of course,
there are some cons and one of
them is the possible slow train
time. Maybe if the RSV D
approximation error is good,
they may then this is not the
case, because the training takes
less than one hour also with one
single GPU. But if you consider
for example, CNN for a very
simple problem, like the one I
shouldn't be for for the
nonlinear conservation law in a
great cake you can take if you
consider a motion to call it
even more than five hours and
time to achieve a good accuracy.
So possible solutions are
represented by transfer learning
or others by petition
approaches. Of course, in other
contexts, that you may require a
large database of snapshots to
achieve a higher accuracy. It's
very difficult to achieve a very
good accuracy with Often
quarters when you have very
difficult PD model, when your
solution presents a lot of small
scale features that you want to
approximate and so, this is a
very, very difficult problem to
obtain more accurate and for our
implementation is more like
lectures because you need them
to solve for this nonlinear
rescore problem. And of course,
there is the problem of
production at some time is not
very robust. So you we may need
one to work on the robustness of
the nonlinear least squares
methodology itself and including
the our production is performed.
And maybe approaches include
regularization, for example. So,
these are the references, or
rocks and they used as open
source software indicating the
value model reduction library
developed form four open form,
and Beiter Betsi. And, of
course, open forum. So, thank
you for your attention. And
these are the references I
already shown you before.
Thank you. Thank you so much for
the wonderful talk, Francisco.
Very nice. Let's have a q&a
sessions. And if you have
questions, please unmute
yourself and ask questions to
Francesco. While you guys are
thinking about it, let me ask,
let me start to ask some
questions. So let's Okay, so you
talked about the teacher student
approach, in slide 26. But
before that the majority of
times you spend on, you know,
the specific kinds of the hyper
reductions where it has a
combination of the linear map.
I'm assuming the linear map is
from SVD. Yes, exactly. Okay,
so. So the, the main idea is you
apply the SVD, and reduce the
dimension a bit and then apply
the deep convolution or
convolution or some sort of the
neural net architecture to
further reduce it. Yes,
yes, exactly. The, the approach
I presented today is not on
teacher student training, but on
this kind of nonlinear
approximate, where the end,
yeah, you have a linear path
with a linear one, the CNN
layers in our case, and then a
linear map from the frequency
space to the, in this case, the
sub mesh, and it's it can be it
can be done efficiently, because
you can restrict the your RSVP
modes on the on the dots you
need for the sub mesh.
Right. Right. So, my question
regarding to that is, as you,
you know, elaborate the
motivation for the nonlinear
manifold reduced order model,
quote, you know, problem with
the Kolmogorov with decaying
slowly. Like, for example,
consider the pure convections.
Right, one of the purposes
moving from left to the right,
yes, if you as we all know, for
that kind of problem, because
the the solution snapshots,
linearly independent, most of
the, it's, you gotta, you need a
lot of activity most, right? And
this approach, since you're
combining, you know, linear SVD,
linear map with neural nonlinear
mapping, isn't it kind of
limited to how much the SVD can
compress your original data? And
if the dog does, so the data is
coming from pure addictions, for
example, then you you create
much like tools, almost like the
full space where we'll space
snapshots, number of snapshots.
So, yeah, so yeah. Can you
comment on? Yes, that's
true. It's true. But maybe
oftentimes, you don't need to I
mean, we actually use a very
high number of modes, I mean,
yeah, very high, but i i And
usually, you have this
Kolmogorov decay problem
asymptotically. So, for some
applications, you may still use
a limited number of LSPD moments
and achieve a satisfactory
accuracy. Also, because let's
say the the introduction case of
is like an extreme case with
respect to some applications,
but some other examples of my
problems, real problems, where
this approach works also only
data driven problem. So, well,
only data driven approach is
tested, can be found for on the
works of Stephanie fresca and
Manzoni. For the while the
extensively tested their pod the
L rom technique, and then
they've shown that also for some
electoral philosophy, theology
test cases So, you may still,
with less than three under
modes, approximate dynamics,
which is abduction dominated. So
really depends on the accuracy
you want to achieve. And of
course, when when you get
problems like the one I've shown
at the end, so in this case, so
when you have also here, I would
say that you have this problem.
So when you cannot approximate
Well, the social manifold, which
has mods, then you would really
need to use a nonlinear
dimension reduction technique.
So yes, this this approach I
presented works in intermediate
regime, let's say, where you can
use when you need to use more
mods than what the number of
mods you would use for a
standard these bases methods,
but still, not too many. And so
for you not to require nonlinear
dimension reduction techniques.
Great. My second question is
about the adaptive hyper
reductions. And there you are
changing a list of magic points
every, like 20 or 50 iterations.
Yes. And once you change the
magic points only the Hyper V
dot center on the linear map is
you have to update it online.
Yes, yes. But you don't change
anything on the nonlinear map?
Yes, yes. Okay, cool. Even
there, like updating the linear
map hyper reduction,
informations, that takes a, you
know, some computational time, I
guess that's why average, the
client stack cost is high.
Yeah, but in this case, we use
only reduce over collocation. So
restricting the mods to just a
sub mesh to a different sub mesh
is very efficient. Now, I guess
the cost really depends on the
number of iterations of your
optimization scheme with which
optimization method to use to
solve the nonlinear least square
problem. Okay, of course, this
is I don't know if in your
experience, but yeah, it's
difficult to get under this
valley. Also, in our
implementation, maybe it's not
as efficient as the code, which
implemented the numerical
solvers open form, since we we
blend it with, say, Python with
a reasonable variation in C++
inside open form. And maybe more
efficient presentation could be
performed, because how, but
sorry,
the efficient implementation
could help.
Yeah, maybe so. Yeah. Maybe
implementing? Everything's
supposed to pass or? Yeah, I
cannot think of maybe in
response. I mean, this isn't may
not be much different with
respect to your single iteration
of your shallow master of
encoders. So maybe, maybe, maybe
it's really the comparison with
the open forum solvers in this
very coarse problems that
sometimes it's not. Sometimes
you're not comparing apples to
Apple, I guess. Yeah. Open Forum
is a C++ and your and your
implementation is on one item.
Yep.
We evaluate the residual
efficiently in C++, but the say
the NACA is on Python. So also
the optimization with the Betsi,
but Pettifor pi. Okay. Simple to
test different techniques. Yes.
Okay. In that sense, there is a
some room for improvement. Okay,
I have a one more questions, if
you if you have time. Yeah,
sure. I really kind of wanted to
see the more about the teacher
student approached. Okay, let me
correct like the slides 26
Because I thought that was
really a kind of killer. Okay.
Killer up in nonlinear manifold,
learning, nonlinear manifold
digital model, in general,
because you do not have to rely
on the that linear map. And
it's, it's, and you can fully
take advantage of the expressive
ability of the, you know, the
neural network with a nonlinear
map. Yeah, what kind of speed up
do you get if you apply this
teacher student training?
I remember that in those cases.
I still I remember where they
actually the grids are the ones
I've shown for a production
here. So we tested it on a Lena
conservation ran on the shallow
water equations. And the grid
was I guess, 60 by 60. So it's
very small problems. So in open
form, and And also in this case,
I guess we could not achieve a
speed up. I mean, we matched the
mean time step, 14 reactivation,
and we managed to achieve a
speed up of true for the shallow
water equations with the
implementation of the teacher
student training network. And
that case also we computed also
data Cobian in a very efficient
manner because we have a two
layer network so we could
evaluate it efficiently.
Okay. And your folder model was
still open form.
Yeah, it was still open form.
Yeah.
Okay. Well, thank you. Is there
any other questions? It's past
the lab and so. Well, thank you
so much, Francisco. It was
wonderful. And I learned a lot.
So that is great. Yeah, if if
anyone has a any question for an
assessable, please reach out to
him directly. I'm sure he's
going to be happy to get any
questions from your base, bone
protector. Francesco. Thank
you. Bye, have a good day.
This is cool.